Bernie Sanders has formally endorsed presumptive
Democratic presidential candidate Joe Biden
and has directed his supporters to vote for
Joe in November.
Now, Bernie Sanders suspended his campaign
last week.
It became clear that he had no mathematical
path to the nomination.
And Bernie now is telling his supporters,
you've got to vote for Joe.
Here is Bernie himself issuing the endorsement
during a call yesterday.
I'm feeling so today.
I am asking all Americans, I'm asking every
Democrat, I'm asking every independent.
I'm asking a lot of Republicans to come together
in this campaign to support your candidacy,
which I endorse, to make certain that we defeat
somebody who I believe from speaking just
for myself now is the most dangerous president
in the modern history of this country.
Very important step for Bernie to be taking.
Noam Chomsky agrees.
This is not you know, the importance of removing
Trump is not a centrist idea.
Prominent progressives, prominent leftists
are making this clear.
Here's Noam Chomsky recently on Democracy
Now!
If Trump is reelected.
It's.
Indescribable disaster.
It means that the policies of the past four
years, which are an extremely destructive
to the American population, to the world,
will be continued and probably accelerated.
The way this is gonna mean for health is bad
enough.
I just mentioned the loss of triggers that
will get worse.
What this means for the environment or the
threat of nuclear war, which no one is talking
about, is extremely serious.
Who's been described as POWs?
Biden has worked in a mine.
I would anticipate it would be essentially
a continuation of Obama.
Think great.
At least not totally destructive on opportunities
for an organized public to change what is
being done.
So this is it.
I mean, listen, I'm with Bernie and I'm with
no chant.
Noam Chomsky on this.
I'm voting for Joe Biden.
And I don't have that much more to add at
this point, because you all know, I've been
laying the case out for a long time.
I am not about vote blue no matter who I am,
not even a Democrat.
I'm about evaluating the choices that we have.
And either Donald Trump will be reelected
in November or Joe Biden will defeat Donald
Trump and will replace him as president of
the United States.
I'm with Biden on that.
And anyone who has seen how Corona virus has
reduced Trump to even more of a dangerously
petulant child yesterday going full authoritarian
during the White House coronavirus press briefing.
I'll have that for you a little bit later.
I can not take any action that will facilitate
Trump getting another four years in good conscience.
Now, I know that you can create these arguments
where you say you don't have to vote, right.
I mean, you can just you can choose not you
can say, I don't like either option and I'm
not voting even if I like one option.
Not exactly the same as the other.
I can still say I'm not voting.
That's totally fine.
And I'm not going to go and attack people
who are doing that.
But you have to understand that on a practical
level, you are acting in a way that gives
makes Donald Trump get one vote closer to
reelection and another four years.
This from Bernie is simply Bernie.
Recognizing that winning is the most important
thing in November.
That's how weaponised Trump's delusions and
ignorance and incompetence are.
Removing Trump is the most important thing
in November.
If Bernie supporters truly trust him, they
should do what Bernie has determined is the
correct path.
This should undermine, by the way, the narrative
from some who are saying Bernie's trying to
hurt Joe Biden's campaign.
Bernie got out last week.
Bernie is unequivocally endorsing Joe Biden
now.
Period.
Now, there will be some Bernie or Busters
who say, I don't care about Bernie's endorsement.
I was never about Bernie as an individual.
I was about Bernie in terms of his policies.
Fine.
There are two people running right now.
It is very clear whose policies are closer
to those of Bernie Sanders.
And it's not Trump.
So how do you in good conscience act in a
way that reinforces Trump getting another
four years?
It could be by voting or it could be by not
voting.
Either way, you have a role to play, and the
idea of not voting as neutral needs to be
tied up in a doggy bag and put in the trash
can.
Not someone else's trash can.
Some people have done in my driveway, but
your own trash can.
But I think you understand the analogy.
Biden and Bernie both want a $15 minimum wage.
Biden and.
Bernie both want back into the Paris climate
deal.
Both want universal gun background checks.
Both are for abortion rights.
Both are for higher taxes on capital gains.
Both are for paid family leave.
Both are for citizenship for DACA recipients.
And I can go on and on.
Biden's not for Medicare for all.
That's true.
He's for lower lowering Medicare to 60 plus
and adding a public option that would give
20 million more people access to Medicare
and it would lower premiums 8 to 9 percent
for everybody else.
Bernie likely wasn't going to get more than
that.
And I know many of you hate me for saying
that, but that's the reality.
So the question is, how does Biden compare
to Trump?
It's night and day on every single one of
those issues.
So I can't control everything.
I have no interest in fighting with people
or telling people that they're bad people
or any of that.
I can control my vote in November and I can
control communicating to you.
Why?
That's my vote.
I'm glad to see Bernie Sanders endorse Joe
Biden.
And I think most of us understand what we
have to do.
If you have 15 seconds, please take a three
questions survey at David.
CNN.com slash survey.
We're trying to see how our how our audience
is affected by Corona virus.
So if you have just 15 seconds, please take
the three questions survey at David Pakman
dot com slash survey.
Totally anonymous.
Three questions takes 15 seconds, maybe 10
of the seconds.
We'll be just pulling up the Web site.
And I'm going to have anonymized results for
you coming up soon.
Let me know on Twitter.
What does Bernie's endorsement of Biden do
for you?
I'm Dean Pacman
on Twitter.